les organes et les satellites vont
peut-être disparaître des toits si vous
habitez en ville vous pourrez bientôt
recevoir france télévisions et d'autres
chaînes par l'intermédiaire de votre
prise téléphonique
une nouvelle technologie qui débute à
peine mais qui en inquiète déjà plus
d'un explication logique bay fo
christian welter plus besoin d'antenne
de parabole satellite ou du câble pour
recevoir la télévision chez vous sous
certaines conditions votre prise de
téléphone suffit en y connectant un
modèle spécifique vous pour en même
temps surfer sur le web
téléphoner et regardez votre télé une
nouvelle technologie lancée aujourd'hui
par un opérateur de télécommunications
grâce à l'adsl l'internet à haut débit
toute cette évolution est possible en
fait parce qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes un
opérateur téléphonique
donc nous avons installé nos propres
équipements dans les centraux de france
télécom et ses équipements sont reliés
directement à la paire de cuivre c'est à
dire à la ligne téléphonique de nos
abonnés
et grâce à ça nous passons maintenant
aussi bien l'internet haut débit que la
têt la téléphonie que l'audiovisuel
programme disponible une centaine de
chaînes dont une vingtaine gratuite
conditions d'accès être situé à deux
kilomètres et demi maximum des centraux
téléphoniques de france télécom
pour l'instant la formule est accessible
dans une vingtaine de villes avec une
même qualité d'image elle vient
concurrencer directement le câble ou le
satellite
il est clair que la télé par satellite
ne tient pas trop a priori avoir
développé un concurrent dans des
programmes comme ce canal ou ceux de tps
ne se retrouveront probablement pas sur
ce type d'offre dont il y aura des choix
qualitatif technique mais également le
contenu
un seul mode de transmission pour le
téléphone l'internet ou la cg cette
technologie réservé pour l'instant aux
zones urbaines va se développer une
bataille commerciale s'engage d'autres
opérateurs comme france télécom vont
bientôt proposer eux aussi à leurs
abonnés la télé via l'internet haut
débit